it's a little bit of curry powder one
carrot one onion
some peanut butter some garlic and some
noodles a list
designed not to intimidate this stir fry
is one of 52
pocket friendly meals created by
michelin star chef
tom carriage that promised to be easy
and affordable
the latter vital when every penny counts
the people that we're trying to help and
reach here are on a budget okay so
frozen virgin tin product works really
well for that because
you only take out what you need we want
kids who are eating toast and cereal for
three meals a day to be actually
engaging in food this is this is where
it's so important for us
at the helm of this project alongside
him the international footballer on the
front line of this cause
last year marcus rashford forced the
government to extend
free school meals for struggling
families this is for adults all children
who don't cook but want to learn
he's crafted these meal tutorials for
beginners
everything we've done um thus far has
been
sort of a you know last minute um
action that we've had to take otherwise
they're gonna they're gonna suffer
dramatically um
so i feel like now they can they can
really put them in a good position to
have a baseline and have a strong start
of of a future that they can look
forward to
the two were brought together by shared
experiences of growing up in
single-parent households on low incomes
they know how crucial food is to
children
and value food banks like this kids
can't concentrate if they're hungry and
their tummies are rumbling so for us
to be able to sort that support those
children and families in need right now
and sadly we feel that demand will grow
you know as furlough's
scheme comes to a close sadly we're
going to see the numbers rise again
every effort is now being made for
families to feel
comfortable in their kitchens so that no
child goes to bed hungry
as the footballer who protected free
school meals is now also
making them himself sky news